your validation means a little to me
happy Thursday everyone so fall is upon
us and the kids are back in class
finally I have the skateboard parked to
myself so I can roller blade
shirtless so what is the LA Unified
School District doing focusing on
Reading Writing and ducking gunfire nope
they're gearing up for National Coming
Out day next week where the ABCs get
replaced by the
lgbts there's nothing wrong with coming
out of course coming out of the closet
implies you live indoors so you're
already one step ahead of many
Californians and jamy
lissow but yeah la schools are planning
a week of action and they do mean action
the district has sent an 11-page tool
kit to elementary school teachers with
lesson plans focusing on identity and
intersectionality of course none of this
was sent to the parents God forbid they
might know what's being fed into their
kids' brains but like everything the
parents are always the last to know it's
part of of California's Fair Education
Act which forces schools to include
lessons on social movements and the
history of people of color disabilities
and LGBT people fine but listen to this
plan which is designed for 6 to 10 year
olds as Heather McDonald at City Journal
explains quote at the week of action
start teachers should engage
kindergarten and first grade students in
discussions about identity aided by an
activity called an identity map wait
having to read a map that's already
unfair to the female students a sexist
would
say but it's not that kind of map here
pupils chart their experiences of
discrimination or privilege along 12
axes including race gender identity
sexuality mental health and body size
that does sound complicated but also a
little evil kids enter a class full of
energy and curiosity and you turn them
into a bitter victim itemizing their
grievances grievances they don't even
have yet so they spend their time
looking at experiences of discrimination
and privilege they're maybe 6 years old
for Christ sake they just learned how to
make a boom boom in the toilet a week
ago and what discrimination exactly
mommy they pick me last to play patty
cake because I have boogers in my
fingernails what privilege what kind of
privilege should a six-year-old site the
ability to fart and make everyone laugh
instead of everyone looking at you like
a monster and what about body size
they're so young they haven't had time
to become fat yet but apparently this
mapping allows seven-year-olds to see
themselves through the lens of
intersectionality teachers then post the
identity maps on the wall for a class
discussion about students multiple
identities yeah multiple identities
we're turning healthy kids into
schizophrenics they walk into class as
themselves and they leave as Mr
Hyde I thought that was funny anyway so
why your first graders learning this
crap do they really need to know what
cisgender means or gender binary or
intersex or pansexual AP class used to
stand for advanced placement now it's an
advanced pervert but here's why it's
what activists want them to learn
because they know it's not organic or
else you wouldn't need to artificially
create and then enforce it but if all
that crap seems pretty Advanced for an
8-year-old it's even worse when you look
at the LA school systems test scores
they're lower than Nancy Pelosi's boobs
terrible that was yeah less than half of
La students meet English language
standards and only onethird meet math
standards remember when they falsely
claimed you can't say gay in Florida
well in La they can't spell it hell they
can't even spell la forget about English
as a second language these kids don't
know it as a first language and they're
way behind at basic skills they're going
to need just to survive making them
perfect fod for a new world of looting
shooting and voting Democrat so forget
about kickball that's just oppressive
and don't even think about giving the
little brat some crayons so they can
trace their hand and turn it into a
turkey that would lead to a discussion
about how that celebrates colonizers and
meat eaters and aists with all five
fingers besides they want your kids to
use their hands for other things at this
point we have only one hope for the
future youthful Rebellion every
generation resists the indoctrination of
the one before it and with any luck this
generation of kids will be no different
just as the punks rejected the hippies
and the Goths rejected the jocks and Joe
Biden rejected his
granddaughter maybe they'll rebel
against all this gender lunacy and all
these efforts to Gaslight them into
believing boys and girls are
interchangeable they'll scoff at
nonsense like gender affirming care and
birthing person and chestfeeding will go
back to its intended meaning eating fish
off a naked woman in a high-end sushi
place they'll do what kids have done
done since time began they'll hate their
teachers I sure did and look where I am
now take that Mrs mccu I got two shows
and you're still buried under my mom's
garage so why bother teaching them
anything at all if we're teaching this
stuff that puts them in an emotional
hole of confusion math and English is
not going to help them when they're
dying their hair purple and changing
their name to the chemical symbol for
magnesium but hey you can't miss what
you never had an educ
if ignorance is bliss America will
become the happiest place on
Earth let's welcome tonight's
guest after seeing his act his kids tell
their friends he's a bus driver actor
writer and comedian Jamie
lissow he's from San Francisco so we
disinfected him with P purel God help me
editor-in-chief of pirate wires Mike
salano salano what's wrong wrong with
me she doesn't parse words or follow her
it's New York Times bestselling author
and Fox News contributor
cattive and finally firemen are called
to rescue cat stuck in his beard New
York Times bestselling author comedian
and former NWA Champion
Tyrus Jamie when the courts allow you to
see your
children are you worried that they might
be brainwashed
yeah I don't think it's the it's more my
kids not the court that don't want to so
that's the hard part I worry about all
this stuff man I worry about like um you
people come out of the closet you should
be able to come out of the closet and be
comfortable doing that I don't know if I
ever told you this but uh in high school
so many people thought I was gay I had
to come out
straight people were like we had no idea
M my parents were like we still love you
just as much
um be careful in that closet though man
there's a lot of G gay quiet sex going
on in there
um at lgbtq have you noticed that every
month there's a new letter right it's
like I think eventually they'll just be
just they'll be like not
F it'll be all the yeah that was pretty
good thank you yeah but it's it's just
all it's all very confusing I I feel bad
for the kids I just don't think they
should make especially with the
affirming care and like being assigned
to I worry about little kids making
decisions that could be permanent with
their little kid brains like I remember
a time when I thought that I should
definitely get a Marvin the Martian
tattoo and this is a lot more serious
than that you know and there's one thing
that confuses me though I don't get um
you imagine being bisexual I feel like
that'd be so it'd be so hard to have to
look at everyone's ass
yeah as they walked
by thank you
Jamie well done all right Mike welcome
to the show first time thank you for
having me I hope you're not regretting
it
um seems like the priorities of our
education is changing what do you make
of this I mean first of all I just think
on the topic of a coming out in
elementary school is just like that it's
insane like you can't uh you can't come
out as a child because gay is homosexual
and children don't have a sexuality
right like that's that's crazy they're
teaching crazy things in school but I
will say I think it's kind of a good
thing that we have this bipartisan
consensus now that academics don't
actually happen in elementary school
because it's what it's just like daycare
right people say this over and over
again it's daycare we need daycare
daycare is cheaper than school so we can
fire all of the gender Goblin teachers
and hire like thousands and thousands of
teenage Camp counselors and I think
everyone's a lot happier right that's
true problem solved kids are happy kids
love Camp they do I love Camp who
doesn't love Camp America loves Camp yes
I'm on the fence you're on the fence
that's cuz you went to fence Camp yeah
it's true that was painful yeah having
to sit on that for days big guy in the
fence wasn't fun yeah so cat uh you can
get fired for talking about this stuff
at work but apparently in classrooms
Elementary classrooms you can just talk
about it at will to children does that
in does that just inflame your senses I
feel like this has to either it's a
coincidence that this stuff only started
becoming a thing after coid or it's some
kind of distraction because like you
said there's been a lot of learning loss
that took place after that and now it's
just people screaming at each other
about gender what was the gender map
yeah like you got a color in a gender
map you're you know you're a bigot or
like there's only two genders you're an
idiot you're rude bigot idiot and
nobody's like oh you know like my kid
doesn't know the colors MH it's crazy so
I also just think that you know I I
don't I think that we should be focusing
more on that and also if this was going
on when I was in school that wouldn't be
good well actually it would have work
well I I was very androgynous looking
mhm and I also loved attention yeah so
I'd be like like I would say I was a boy
for sure yeah and also kids will take do
it will will accept anything that isn't
like doesn't create homework or is
actually taxing all right Tyrus do you
think this is like another luxury belief
except now that it's spreading to kids
no I what I first of all if you can
homeschool get your kids out of school
yeah because they're not learning
anything and the stuff they're teaching
them um is dangerous so there's two
Sexes you're either born a man or a
woman that's it now you can pretend to
be whatever you want but that's the
facts and if you don't believe me go to
England because they're the only ones
who will say it out loud now
but when you don't have numbers because
we always bring this up what is the
percentage what are the numbers how many
people are we talking about that are in
this category of the of the gender this
and gender that and and all this kind of
stuff and whenever we ask we're bigots
mhm so I get the sneaking suspicion that
the number is not as big enough as they
want the people who who are pushing this
want it to be so what do you do you got
to make new members and where do you
start with children you try to push your
way of thinking your way of living on
children so you create what members of
your group then because before when they
would protest there's nine of them you
know would be like well where's the huge
numbers of PE and it's always a big
secret so now what they're doing is
these individuals are they they can't
create their own fast enough so first
thing you do is parents are bad they
don't need to know what's going on stay
away from Mom and Dad you can trust us I
mean they're saying the same things that
every creepy pedophile said in a van
outside your house but now they're not
in Vans outside your house they're in
your school and they're on your internet
and you're on your tablet when you let
you're not paying attention to your kids
so the scary thing to me is that this is
not simply they don't want you smart
because when you're smart you ask
questions so if you don't know how to
read very good you don't know how to
problem solve very good math is a racist
mystery to you and you just believe that
you can be anything on this box whenever
you feel like it it's a pretty good way
to get people indoctrinated with a
little work and why is it more I don't
think it's going to be effective because
parents are going to fight back because
if you do have a gay child at home or a
child that's going that route your job
as a parent is to protect them and guide
them not tell them what to do right so
it's it's a as a parent all my kids are
out of public school oh and also I'm a
little Disturbed that you think okay
never
[Applause]
mind I it's bothering me I can't believe
that you think 6 years old is when kids
are potty trained yeah well that was I
was just going by personal experience
off girls they get it at 3 boys 5 and
six is about right like just I don't
know what it is you guys are just scary
about the toilet when you were a kid I
remember learning it like 8 years old
and then losing it again when I started
drinking well they they teach you the
right way to sit facing the right
direction yeah when you're little and
then when they tell boys to turn around
it just blows our mind we just can't
make that
switch hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else